I meet two young people who have already
left their home countries Ali and his
friend Mohammed to say they didn't have
any choice we are here to see an
exhibition of photos selfies taken by
other refugees who fought to stay in
Germany however in the end most were
deported mirror husband Ali and his
friend recognize some of them this place
became a symbol for refugee protests
across Germany and just struggle for
acceptance for over two years a group of
asylum seekers camped out on the spot
before they were evicted by the police
over the years the number of refugees
coming to Germany has continually risen
but only about twenty percent get to
stay Ali is afraid he'll end up like the
other eighty percent well either has
rats reservoir and Sofia lasted ten
whole year last week or Demi sauce
McConnell Khalid Ansari sharpshooter
Viceroy de que nada reduce kinsey rebar
pomona Madame the Gutenberg decay had to
shave on me album as this described
after Habib named Eva ya que so we'll
have to bid our mission perfectly as
some Cairo cigar but I'm to test me
McGee after I am Rosa Harry Calman
awesome yeah Adama Diarra us at alutia
now
this is the refugee center where Ali
lives freedom of movement is something
refugees in Germany long for every night
Ali has to check back in here the center
on the farthest outskirts of Berlin some
refugees have to live in sports halls
others live in flats
I know I know we did Alice good dog i'm
allie has been living here for one year
and four months this would he has to
stay at the center while German
authorities examine his application for
asylum or the man and dad could take
several more years until then he's not
allowed to go to university or hold a
real job ok once to me gentlemen yeah
meet under Herman yeah on heir kommt aus
even ok Candice Bergen per dish yeah and
so does it say would ya he tells me he
was allowed to help with the community
project it only paid one euro an hour
but it was enough to buy this smartphone
Yohan Cabaye London kegger Massimo
called poonam jyot jorma kaukonen Bella
have eaten a bit suzuki at that Alec and
she shouldn't be our dispersor wassup
Cass idea but it was making web browser
should be Thomas despotism a machinima
monica by check or a swedish aversa
octoberish meters have foreign reserves
walkin after hey Dyl Oh meatball mission
the failen my boy we see you only worry
he'll equal to negative top bamidele MK
Gertie almond be manam shred the tanami
I aetna at an enormous horde em casa de
Xiang Yu SI jo mohabbat anima demo
videos
Ali has been a refugee all his life he
grew up in Iran raced by Afghan parents
in Iran Afghans are excluded from
society and face massive discrimination
Ali says the police arrested him and his
family choice just for who they are
Marilyn his death sollima but we his
dad's alma hitch as not another typical
mamali a kiss for me okay Oviatt a
mimosa hudso but guitar involve an
economy who yet on we're gonna be yet
big john mayer to ache kiss fell
technical sanjay too a Levite estava the
Doozer Kalahari enjoy muah from moshe
has kanika Xavier timid she has hello
Ali came to Germany all alone at a time
he was just 17 with his family half a
world away it's up to him to navigate
this new culture and country on his own
I follow our latest german classes there
a chance for him to get out of the
dreary shelter and go into town just a
couple of years ago asylum seekers like
Ali didn't have access to language
courses tremella no madam Jami Dunham
care to Al Mamun danny has some yummy
stone but they hope to certain cakes
that wanted Eddie the yacht pilgrim to
Sir MK but Joe me I'll Monica do
international star peter hounam yo mammy
dalam que tan hobo Sobotka damn yo gift
and szczepaniak Malak admitted in Qatar
jorma yo que han geng jumeirah damn papi
Zara Alice's learning German is hard
work that's something I can identify
with it has been a big challenge for me
too when I came here
so the classes are a welcome distraction
from Ali's constant fear he might be
deported don't ya don't simmer on the
Patel FEMA on Vaughn Seema the adornment
marhaban kinda unknown was diluted it
cannot happen often vigna torrent
whether in Europe I didn't land was
founded a formula frozen well
marshmallows easement in delhi cantt had
an staff delighted to 3d environments of
filtrate register lived hard on the
stock to Africa but they are under and
they are torturing the firkin of these
allotted suits again in a hill
philanthropy the city trains can be a
luxury means of transportation when you
don't have enough money to buy a ticket
Ali is used to walking a lot around in
Berlin
twice a week Ali comes to an even bigger
refugee shelter to play football with
the children who live here he's their
coach and Dementor like him some of
these children have experienced
prejudice and discrimination from the
time they could walk they know that not
everyone appreciates their presence here
in Germany boy yeah dancer wiper ok
Ashley elf Mehta has trained together
cartel I still Salim Aquino masala is
the restaurant guy enjoyed our album me
Mon Ami and Emma moanin very hope
Jessica method Rebecca damask football
yay k meet another mysterious to Hoonah
by them in the most part with the
maternal damas up with the photographer
[ __ ] hot pizza after the whole money
imma do it champ but madam on it was a
condom in Java meniscus an omission of
Tom Valastro football for the ritalin as
liquid n star sister your fish there to
stay on monitor on verra million ok
football boys miss a comma better
non-contact which terrified of all the
better number John me on mon Dieu
stabbed Robert accredo column Ali it
doesn't want to be considered just a
refugee he wants to be accepted as a
full member of society I'll be checking
in with him again soon to see if he
succeeds